Meet Boyan.
One day, when he went diving at sea, he noticed more plastic bags than fish.
Plastic bags and other trash left behind...
...end up in rivers and travel to the open water.
There, currents push the trash around and concentrate it in huge areas.
The trash gets eaten by animals, so it even makes its way back to us.
Boyan wondered, "How can we get all this plastic out of the ocean?"
This was the start of "The Ocean Cleanup."
When Boyan was 17,...
...he came up with a plan for an installation to clean our oceans.
After presenting this,...
...he gained the support of a hundred scientists, engineers and volunteers,...
...who together established that the concept is feasible.
This is how it works.
The trash floats towards a hundred kilometer wide barrier.
Sea life safely passes underneath,...
...while the current pushes the plastic towards the centre.
Here a conveyor belt and a pump scoop up the plastic.
A ship comes by every six weeks to pick up the trash for recycling.